Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Byrd is time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 6th,
2016.
This is like the fifth fucking time I've tried to start this thing because,
uh,
I dunno,
I just had an aborted landing.
Well,
I didn't have one.
The pilot had one and uh,
I was riding in the back in the end.
What are you going to do?
What we landed safely,
you know,
some airplane didn't clear the runway.
That was my fifth one that I've had.
I've had five of boarded landings and that was my second one at lax.
Um,
first one was vehicle on a runway and this next one,
a guy didn't plane was still on the runway,
didn't clear it or whatever,
but uh,
it was a little less scary.
Now that I've flown a little bit,
you know,
not a lot but a little bit,
but uh,
you still in the back and you can't see what's going on.
So that's,
that's always nice.
Um,
all right.
So people have been asking me,
they've been emailing me,
they'd been twittering me,
they'd been Facebooking me,
um,
about what's going on with these Irish dates.
Uh,
Dublin,
July 31st,
Belfast,
August 1st in Galloway,
Galway,
modal Ireland on the 2nd of August.
All right.
I have the presale information,
but for whatever reason I'm not allowed to announce it,
but I'm going to win.
I got to tell you when he went announce it.
I'm going to announce it on six,
nine,
16 at 4:00 PM GMT time,
whatever that means.
Gaelic Gaelic mountain to Katie to time.
All right.
Um,
why can't I just say when the fuck this shit's going to be all right.
June 10th is when they're going on sale.
I'll announce the presale on the ninth.
Ow.
Fuck this.
I'm going to tell you everything now.
All right.
Hundred nine 16 at 4:00 PM,
uh,
the presale will be announced.
No,
right?
Just this is why I had to rerecord it.
This is so fucking confusing.
The presale for Dublin,
Ireland is going to be June 10th.
My birthday,
2016 at 9:00 AM Gaelic mountain time.
All right.
Um,
and then the regular on sale is going to be June 13th,
9:00 AM GMT time,
whatever the fuck that means.
All right.
And um,
Belfast is going to be about five days later and so's Gallway a gateway modal
Ireland,
um,
will be that.
That'll be June 15th.
MMM.
So that's the deal.
All right.
And I'll let you guys know,
I'll just,
I'll tweet about it.
I'll do all that shit so nobody gets fucked out of anything.
Also,
there's been a second show added in London,
England,
MMM.
For August six,
2016.
Uh,
we'll have a link up there for that and I'll let shit,
all right.
There you go.
I got all the business stuff out of the way and also go to all things,
comedy.com be sick of listening to me.
We got a bunch of other talented people out there that you can listen to.
Um,
and with that,
let's get into the podcast.
Ah,
I around [inaudible] it's still acting up.
I'm going to every fucking witch doctor out here at this point.
I don't give a shit.
You know,
some woman was talking to me was saying how she got Sciatica when she was
pregnant and I was just like,
he called me fat and she,
she laughed.
She's like,
no,
she goes,
I just,
I just got it.
And uh,
she went someplace and she goes,
they just kind of lightly just with on my backside.
I thought they were really going to need in there and they just kind of lightly.
You want to like what the,
nobody's fucking putting leaves on my butt cheeks.
I'm getting what everybody else first before that.
Um,
but I got to tell you,
like something happens with the air pressure when I'm on a plane,
the back of my leg,
it feels like my hamstrings gonna snap a.
So I've got to keep standing up doing my Vietnamese gambler fucking squat and
um,
I dunno,
trying to stretch out the PSOAS muscle.
I'm doing everything I can to try to keep this thing at bay because I don't
fucking have the time to take care of it.
I just don't,
I'm too fucking busy here with a writing this filthy wonderful cartoon,
which I'm having a great time doing at bopped episode six this week.
People up to episode six writing as far as far as that aspect of it.
I literally signed the fucking rain man.
All right,
let me take it through my trip here.
All right.
I had some fucking guy,
he was like in his early sixties gift me this fucking look like he was gonna
Punch me in the face to the point I had to say something to them and I know you
guys are thinking like,
Bill,
what the fuck you talking shit to a guy 63 well I'm going to be 48 this week.
So you know when I was 15 he was 30 so it's not that bad.
We're,
we're pretty close.
Right.
When I was 10 he was 25 right.
You know,
you think he wouldn't have picked on me back then is what happened.
Right.
So I went down,
go around the airport,
right.
I got bumped up the business.
So I get to go first.
I get to go into the lounge,
right.
They get to go in and fucking pour myself some corn flakes or whatever.
So I go into the lounge and there's this fucking guy,
right.
He just,
I dunno,
I just,
I got on the elevator and he was there and he was kind of in my space,
but he was a little oblivious or whatever.
Right.
Fucking horseshoe level bald and he dies the sides,
which is always hysterical to me.
Like,
dude,
what the,
why you still dying that you think that makes you look younger?
Um,
so anyways,
it's like five in the fucking,
it's before five in the morning because that's what time my flight is.
And you know,
I go up to the lounge and I sat my shit down.
He goes as other way.
I'm not even thinking about this guy.
And then I'm walking over to where the cereal is and so is he all right?
Like two planes about to land,
you know,
on the same runway.
I'm in front of them,
I have priority.
So I walk over there and then he,
I feel him standing way close to close to me.
And when I finished,
you know,
I just did a couple of turns,
the fucking Syrah thing,
couple turns of the KNOB and it goes into the ball and then I pour some milk in
it.
It probably took me less than 15 seconds to do that.
And when I turned around because I just felt them,
I want to turn the other way,
but I felt him on my left shoulder turn and looked at him and he was glaring at
me showing me all of his bottom teeth,
you know,
was like,
except he wasn't making that noise.
But you know the face you make when you,
eh,
that's what,
when he was looking at me,
just glaring at me.
Okay,
so what the fuck did I say to him?
I just looked down,
I was like,
I remember I said,
are you,
I got you are,
you are right.
That's what I said.
Are you all right?
And then he didn't say anything.
And then I felt bad like,
oh man,
was,
was he like one of those old guys?
Remember I did that bit.
The old man face was that,
is that the beginning of the old man face?
You start glaring at first and then you gradually get more scared?
I have no idea.
Right.
Um,
okay.
It's like those old people know they're going to hell but think it back on their
life and they're trying to think they have enough time to say enough hair,
hail Mary's.
And they just realize they can do,
they probably saw ghosts and saw those creepy things coming up from hell.
So anyways,
he didn't say anything.
So I walk away and I'm thinking that feeling bad.
Like,
Oh man,
I,
uh,
you know,
I just fucking yelled at that old,
I didn't yell at the old guy,
but I kind of keep them shit,
you know,
so I felt bad then went over to sit down and then he gets his fucking cereal and
at this point,
you know,
I'm like,
I'm like fucking 20 yards away from this guy,
sit down.
And He fucking turns around.
And as he,
he's walking over to his wife,
he looks at me and shakes his fucking head up.
So he was glaring at me.
Yeah.
So later I go to get up to get a fucking apple and I knew we was going to be
looking at and I looked right over at him and I,
I can't remember what the fuck I did.
And then I was like,
really built,
are you really doing this?
Neither one of these is going to fight.
You're both too fucking old to fight.
And uh,
that's how my trip started.
So I should've known that it was going to be a weird travel experience.
Um,
ended up getting into a Syracuse.
That's what I was going the first night.
And we played this minor league hockey arena and a,
I didn't know at the time until I got there.
They actually,
uh,
filmed,
um,
that's where they filmed slap shot a lot of it when they did all this stuff,
you know,
I'm listening to the fucking song when they were on the key,
uh,
the ice and everything,
so that was cool as shit.
Um,
the next night we did another one of those small hockey arenas and they,
that one they told me that was the place Elvis was supposed to perform at.
Um,
but he died the day before.
That was his next concert.
And so they still have all these Elvis tickets and they actually gave me this
little frame thing of a couple of Elvis tickets.
And then the date that I played there was really fucking cool.
Um,
what the fuck did I go
after that?
Oh,
then I went down to ball.
I was driving from Portland back to fucking Albany.
Who's kidding?
Who?
I wasn't fucking far as he was riding.
We were in this SUV and I was laying down in the back seat because my fucking
leg was killing me.
Um,
it shits really starting to scare me,
man.
Like how fucking long is this going to take?
I've been dealing with this shit since February.
Every time I start to turn the corner,
I got to get on a plane again.
So
people who stare at me too,
when I stand up on the plane,
I squat down.
I don't even give a fuck.
And they're just looking at me.
I told you the last time this guy asked me if I was praying.
So,
um,
anyways,
then the final show last night was in Albany,
but I actually,
when we drove from Portland,
which so many memories came back,
we went over that bridge when we went over this bridge in a,
where you go from New Hampshire to Maine.
And I remember I used to fucking,
one of my first girlfriends used to live over there,
Brandon,
the other side of that.
What?
She didn't live there,
she lived down in the Boston area,
but she had like family up there.
I remember going up on over that bridge.
I always think of that shit.
I always think about the ticket that I got on the fucking turnpike up there,
driving my piece of shit truck back.
Um,
the comedy connection up there,
all of that shit.
And,
um,
I gotta tell you man,
just living out here in la,
like all people in New York for Mont New Hampshire in Western mass in Maine,
I hope they realize how fucking lucky they are to live where it rains and
there's all that lush land.
I'm so fucking jealous of that shit.
Like when I came back,
um,
we,
when we were driving from Portland to,
uh,
Albany,
I actually went down to the Boston area to visit some family and friends and
stop off and one of my favorite pizza places and uh,
we can't ended up coming down route one and the fucking memories that were
coming back,
it was a strip club up there.
There was the hilltop steakhouse would say now completely knocked down.
I hope that sign,
cause it's still up that giant fucking cactus.
I hope somehow like that thing is protected.
You know what I mean?
You know,
it's funny.
That's like one of those dumb things.
They'll sell on fucking Ebay for like 1 million bucks and it'll say like 15
people are watching this,
you know,
do you know,
like,
like back in the day how they used to,
they used to catch people with warrants.
They would just have a,
like during like a fight or something,
they would just advertise,
hey,
you're the,
you're the 20th person to order this.
Come down here and claim your free gift.
And they'd call these people up and they would all got out and claimed the gifts
and then I'll be all these people standing around down there and then the cops
would just walk in and they'd fucking arrest everybody.
Um,
they should fucking do that with,
with dumb shit like that on Ebay.
Like the giant,
the hilltop steakhouse,
right?
There's 15 people watching it.
Those 15 should immediately be audited.
Who would have,
who the fuck's got 1 million bucks to blow on a giant lit up cat?
I mean,
everybody wants it.
Well,
not everybody.
I'd love to have that fucking thing,
you know,
get yourself a spread out in the middle of nowhere.
You have a giant lit up cactus,
your friends come over,
right.
Just don't make a right at the giant cactus.
You know,
you get a nickname out of it all.
Cactus Chris,
he's fucking crazy.
Um,
but nobody has the money to do that shit.
Right?
Like I went on Ebay,
right.
And I was uh,
I don't the fuck I was looking,
I was trying to,
you know,
kill the flight now.
Now you can,
you know,
go online.
So I was just looking up random shit like,
uh,
humidors even though I've gotten cigars mostly out of my life,
I was just looking him up cause I think they're fucking cool.
Right.
Well I know when I was doing,
I was looking at cigar affection auto and they had all these,
you know,
cool places where you can smoke a cigar.
They let you know in different cities like places to smoke and shit.
Right?
Like I already find a cool place in London.
Um,
possibly just smoke.
We'll see.
And uh,
that is,
if I smoked it,
I don't know.
We'll figure it out anyways.
Uh,
and that just got me thinking about cigar smoking and all that type of shit.
So I went on Ebay and a lot of the shit that comes along with cigar smoke and
it's pretty fucking cool.
A lot of the lighters,
a lot of the ash trays and the humor doors.
And I like looking at that stuff,
especially if they're vintage or old.
So I look up vintage humor door.
I'm sure it's still there.
And this,
this,
this is fucking,
I think it's sitting bull.
It's this bust of sitting bull.
All right.
That's what the fuck and humidors it's a bust of sitting bull and what's really
fucking,
you know,
weird is to to,
put your cigars in it.
You basically take off the scalp,
which I thought was a little fucking tacky,
but granted it's old.
That was considered a Mike.
Totally fine back in the day.
Right?
Um,
so anyways,
this fucking thing is going for a million and a half dollars
and it has in it,
it says like,
there's like 20 people watching.
I'm looking it up right now.
ebay.com.
All right.
Okay.
Vintage humidor.
Boom.
All right.
What do you got?
Oh fuck.
What the hell is it?
Oh,
there it is,
right?
Yeah,
they're sitting bull cigar store,
Indian statue,
Antique American folk art,
vintage tobacco.
You know,
it's funny from the side it actually looks cool from straight on.
It just looks like,
I dunno,
it's kind of looking off big.
He kind of look sad and then they,
I don't understand why.
Okay.
Sing is a million and a half bucks to 61 people watching this 61 people have a
million and a half dollars to spend on a fucking humidor.
I Dunno.
Like that's the type of shit right there.
Like if I was dodging taxes and all that type of shit,
you know,
go out and do this on the Internet.
Right.
I Dunno.
That's like when every year we are watch shows Meekum car auctions.
You know when somebody spends 500 grand on a fucking Mustang,
I mean you're either,
you're either evading taxes or you're a wife beater,
one of the other.
Okay.
But you are either cheat,
cheating the fucking system or your wife is scared to death of you that she's,
she'll let you fucking do that.
Blow a million and a half bucks on a humidor looking at Ani in a great Saint
Paul look at the top of his head comes off
like after a fucking autopsy.
Um,
anyways,
so I didn't came,
can't remember the hell I was talking about here.
Oh.
So we end up having to just having this great anytime I work with for Z,
we have a great fucking time.
Um,
when we were up in Portland after the show,
we had a great time working there,
the uh,
the Elvis venue there and um,
we ended up going up to this bar afterwards and game three of the Stanley Cup
finals and uh,
the UFC fights were both on and Jesus Christ,
Dan fucking Henderson.
Do you guys see that knock out?
That was like some Bourne identity shit.
He threw a kick,
went passed the guy and then fucking threw an elbow.
Like he was training in a phone booth.
I've never seen anything like that.
And Ryan,
a long time ago,
I saw a UFC fighter basically throw a left hook,
but he did it with his knee.
He fucking got rocked in their head.
I think it was that guy that used to call the little bottle,
a little ball of hate,
the hell was his name.
One of my favorite fighters back then.
Right.
He had his hair dyed like bright red fire engine red and he got rocked and he
started to go down and the other guy was so excited to jump on and start hitting
him that he kind of just went in with his hands down a little bit and the
fucking guy was able to regroup and he just,
I can't explain it.
He threw it.
He need the guy in their head,
but he like came from the side.
He threw a hook that's fucking guy went down,
gave him the old right there.
Fred with the left knee,
Dan Anderson,
the same fucking thing.
This guy was just,
he was getting punched in the head repeatedly and everybody in the bars got,
oh right.
And I'm yelling and I actually for once,
because I don't know shit about fighting,
I will go,
but he's fucking eat and those punches,
I'll look at them and uh,
the next,
you know,
it kicks the guy in the fucking head.
He kicked him in the head and then somehow he was like parallel to the guy's
head and he gave me fucker near with the elbow and the guy just went down.
That was it over.
And then the coolest thing ever was,
his family was there,
you know,
tell me,
you don't have the coolest dad ever.
Guy Goes shirtless in the ring,
eats fucking 12 punches to the head and then knocks the other guy out.
You know?
You know,
it was funny.
He was in better shape than his.
He's a 45 year old guys.
Should have the dad bod.
He's up there as shredded.
His kids are coming up,
you know,
he's making them look soft.
That's the ending was soft.
I'm just saying,
usually by the time you're 45,
you have three,
four kids.
You just got that 600 yard stare.
Like,
you don't give a fuck if you're eating a twinkie or a fucking tube sock,
you know,
and this guy is up there,
just was shredded.
So once again,
once again,
the UFC completely the fucking money
he paid to get in.
I missed all the other phone.
Oh No,
I saw the uh,
the championship one with a guy there that I've been watching ever since.
He was on the ultimate fighter,
the guy from Manchester,
England.
Ah,
fuck.
I got to get his name here.
God dammit.
Um,
I,
you know,
I realized when he won,
I had been saying his last name wrong forever.
UFC Champ Manchester.
Here we go.
What's his name?
Michael Bisbing.
I was,
I was Biz Bane.
Michael Bisman,
he fucking one.
That was another great one.
Um,
what a night.
And then as we,
and as we're watching that simultaneously they're watching.
Uh,
well I guess I was probably the only one really watching it,
but I was watching the uh,
Penguins San Jose and I'm looking at this shit going like holy fuck,
it's two to one that carrying the play and all of a sudden they get a high
stick.
I think it was a four minute power play.
They seem like they were on the power play for fucking ever long story short
through up to two to one in the game and there was like they killed off like
all,
all fucking 20 minutes of this penalty.
It seemed like a 20 minute penalty.
Right.
They killed his fucking thing off.
This is like two seconds left and all I'm thinking in my head is if they kill
off this penalty,
they're going to win this game and they're going to win the cup.
This is the fucking series and it's over three to score out of nowhere.
I don't know it,
I don't know if it was tipped or whatever.
After San Jose's goalie made this one of the sickest fucking like saved it with
like the inside of his forearm,
you know,
a few minutes early.
And then at any let that one go in little bit of a floater and now it's two
games to one.
Right.
And I don't give a fuck either way.
My team's out of it.
And then my surrogate team has also a lot of it all I know is that means that
there's going to be at least one more game,
a hockey right as far as,
rather than,
than just going for games,
that'll go five.
Right.
So we at least got two more games,
which is good for me because,
uh,
when,
when the NHL and the NBA seasons and I have like a sort of sports panic attack
because they haven't watched been watching baseball.
I don't know what the fuck's going on in baseball,
but all I know it's like the middle of the season,
you know,
Diet.
Here's the rubber game,
just a all outside and you're gonna see that Slat or a lot this afternoon.
You know,
after you,
this went from like watching people win championships and playing at that level.
Um,
that's why the NFL is the shit as far as like,
it actually compete with October baseball because you figured that the middle of
the NFL season would be boring.
Like most,
most sports,
the middle of the season is boring when you play like 80 to 162 gangs.
But NFL only play 16 games.
Every game means so fucking much,
you know?
Um,
okay.
Plus Tom Brady ought to be coming back from his nice rest,
a nice rest,
relaxed,
pissed off.
Tom Brady coming back to light you up again.
You know,
you guys can look under the rocks and try to figure out what he's doing someday,
someday you will admit that he fucking was,
you know,
I was just a shit.
Um,
and then the saddest thing obviously the weekend was,
uh,
was the death of Muhammad Ali.
Man,
that guy,
if,
if you've never watched when we were kings.
MMM.
I used to watch,
I used to own that thing and I used to,
I wore it out.
I had it on VHS then he had on a DVD and I just,
I've watched it so many fucking times.
I just,
um,
okay.
I don't even know how to put the guy in the words.
It was literally like one out of,
I watched it.
I was like,
I have not done shit with my life.
The guy was unbelievable.
And when I to,
I tweeted,
you know,
greatest of all time,
greatest athlete,
ambassador,
human being of all time and all these,
you know,
Twitter cons,
come on bill.
He just,
he hit things in a ring.
It's like,
no,
he didn't,
he did so much stuff beyond that.
Yeah.
Like,
you know,
it says how great mom and I leave was like,
when I said greatest human ever,
it said,
really?
They're like better than Gandhi.
And it's like,
exactly.
Exactly.
If I said fucking Tom Brady,
you know,
greatest ever you,
you,
you just going to bring up other quarterbacks.
You had to bring up fucking Gandhi.
This is a goddamn athlete.
That's a good comparison.
Cause he was doing Gandy Shit outside of the ring and he could knock out anybody
in the world.
The guy could hold court and the poorest of the poor right up to the White
House.
When he walked in,
he lit up the room.
Everybody shut up and you never forgot it.
And uh,
and on top of that,
he was one of the greatest fighters of all time,
if not the greatest.
MMM.
And I got so much out of when I used to watch that you don't,
when he was talking all that shit.
MMM.
It was like,
he was almost,
as much as he was talking shit,
he was like,
it was like self help.
It's not the way it's done today where today it's just all like,
it's all perverted.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know what's going to happen if you say the crazy shit.
You know that your hype and the fight,
you know that you're going to get a sneaker deal.
You know all this money's coming.
I'm not saying that he didn't know that on some level,
but
okay.
The shit that that guy went through.
MMM.
If you watch some of those early,
especially the ones that are in black and white,
the fucking white reporters is so God damn racist.
It's like ridiculous.
I remember when he just going and and going and this reporter's gets white guys
getting fucking Matt.
He just hates his confidence.
This guy,
like if this guy could have got sent into the future,
he'd be a hater on Twitter.
So he finally just goes,
do,
do you ever stop talking?
I'll at least said something like now,
cause I'm knocking out all bumps and if you keep talking I'm knocking you out
too.
And he just,
it was the greatest.
He just fucking piss the guy off and he knew what the guy was doing and he was
able to navigate all of that.
I know everybody says all the terrible shit that he did to Joe Frazier,
but nobody gets out of this life without some bad shit.
Everybody's done some bad shit.
You know what I mean?
But,
um,
I dunno man,
he still had a good run though,
70,
74 years.
Um,
I used to watch them when I was a kid.
Man,
that's how fucking old I am.
That's what's freaking me out now was all these people that were like in their
twenties and thirties when I was a kid are now dying of like fucking old age and
shit.
David Bowie,
Mohammed Ali,
that's fucking freaking me out.
You know what I mean?
Maybe that's why that guy at the,
uh,
at the little cereal thing in the fucking at the airport was giving me that look
because he knows he's going to,
you know,
everybody he knew is probably all dead right.
And He's thinking,
I only got so much time left to get cereal.
You know,
I was also thinking the fact that he felt so fucking like the little,
like the complete lack of patients that he had and I don't have patients,
the fact that that he couldn't wait two seconds for me to get some fucking
Cerios I was also thinking like that's probably why he's in this lounge.
This guy just fucking
take doesn't take no for an answer.
He's a lunatic.
Um,
I don't know.
That's kind of fucking depressing shit that'll be talking about death.
Cause I gotta tell you though,
I like the amount of fucking people that have died in the last goddamn year,
that I am old enough to have been a teenager and seeing them in their fucking
prime.
Um,
how about that Prince Shit?
Huh?
Another person lost to the opiates and stuff.
I just can't put my,
it's like,
I can't believe it,
but the fact that they actually come at him and they come at fame and celebrity
and all that type of shit,
like people are fucking dying.
Regular people are dying because of that drug.
However the fuck you say,
fentanyl or whatever the hell it is,
they get it.
Then the prescription runs out.
They were addicted to opiates and then they get on heroin.
And the fact that they don't talk about the pharmaceutical companies at all is
because that's like 150 fucking zillion dollar business and they give money to
the politicians and they advertise on TV.
So they make like prince out to be like this.
Um,
this famous guy that,
you know,
nobody could say no to.
I mean,
I might be wrong in this,
but I know he had at least one hip replacement if not two.
And if you ever watch the guy,
the guy never took a show off.
He was all over the fucking stage.
I imagine he was in pain and that's how that shit started was basically him
pouring his heart out on stage,
giving everybody 100%.
He wore out his fucking hips.
What's this?
James Brown did the same thing.
He had to get new hips.
Um,
fortunately by the time prince got the operation,
hopefully they were further along and uh,
but I,
I imagine he still had all kinds of pain and then I,
that's,
that's my guests.
But for the fact that people came at them,
some people,
the way that they came at him was,
uh,
I don't know,
considering the shows and,
and in the music that he left us,
I thought it was really fucking,
ah,
it's a little below the belt though.
When you say,
I think that's a little below the belt.
Have you guys seen this youtube video?
My name is John Dacre.
You got to watch this thing.
I apologize cause it's going to be in your fucking head for the rest of the
time.
I'll,
I'll post the,
um,
the video,
to,
uh,
my,
my Twitter account.
He's singing,
he's singing a moray and he can't remember how to,
I can't stop watching this guy.
This guy,
I swear to God,
I think it's his first TV Gig.
Somebody was sick.
I think they say at the beginning,
this guy fills in and if you look at him,
he's literally having an out of body experience.
So it's so funny to me because I can relate to this person because the first
time I did stand up I felt like I was watching myself.
I've fucked everything up and this guy,
just the way he says his name,
it's almost just,
he says like,
my name is John [inaudible].
Yeah,
yeah.
It's like,
it's like he was outside,
so I think that might be my favorite part of the video is the one this fucking
guy,
just the way he says his own name,
he didn't say,
my name is John Dacre.
He goes,
my name's John Taker.
See,
I did it right the first time I,
and I just fucked it up.
Hey Yo,
you gotta hear this.
You got to his fucking guy.
He says he's singing all these Jesus songs.
Hang on,
hang on.
My name is John Dick or
yeah,
that's the funniest shit ever.
My name's John Taker.
It's like he's watching his life,
like he already died
and then he came back and he just got to
like,
he first time you ever realize my name,
my name is John Taker.
That's my fucking name.
And this is my life and I'm on TV and I'm going to sing this song.
This is what I did with my life.
And then you look at the guy,
fucking poor bastard.
Um,
anyways,
did Da,
k,
e r.
F.
If you're just listening now and you want to fucking watch it at work,
um Oh my God,
listen to him sing.
Hallelujah.
Ugh.
Damn.
But for the grace of God,
this fucking guy would be the most interesting interview ever.
Just like,
he's one of the most fascinating people I've ever seen.
Like what the,
what is going on in between those fucking ears right now?
I think if they could,
if you could make a show about his fucking thoughts,
you know,
all these fucking movies.
Oh,
it's,
yeah.
You know,
they show the movie,
but it's done in reverse.
And then they try to fucking flip you out.
Nothing.
Nothing pink Floyd could ever fucking right.
Can match what's going on in this guy's head.
Highly recommended.
All right,
let's read 'em.
Let's read some,
a little bit of a average days in there.
Um,
bells will ring,
ring and doing a doing that some more.
Um,
what the fuck is the God damn,
my name is John Taker.
All right.
Oh,
me undies.
Me undies.
No more sweaty taint,
dude.
Dude,
me undies,
me undies.
There's so dry.
You're gonna Faint and fall into a puddle Dick fucking first.
But don't fucking worry.
Your underwear was absorb it.
Just like one of those pamper commercials.
Throw it in to the ocean.
Oh yeah.
And kill a bunch of fucking dolphins.
All right.
Mandy's everybody,
whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
you spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear,
but instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
clothes,
your pro,
your underwear is probably boring.
Beyond is,
is here to change that.
Uh,
every pair of me,
Andy's is made from sustainably sourced modal,
modal more.
I'm going to keep saying this and t,
tell me which one to accent,
right?
It's like a one syllable word like bike,
you know,
bicycle.
It's on the sick,
right?
What was on the buy?
Oh,
fucking no.
Anyways,
every pair of me undies is made from sustainably sourced mortal.
Oh ooh.
Of Fabric.
That's twice as soft as cotton.
I'll tell you right now,
John Drake or didn't have on me undies,
even if he did not even modal,
could fucking absorb the sweat pouring down his fucking balls.
Nothing can describe the fit of the fields of me undies,
feeling me undies.
Don't you to try them on.
You'll understand while they are called the world's most comfortable underwear.
Uh,
please,
there's somebody in the Lewminatti probably has boxes made out of an endangered
species,
right?
Baby Seal fucking briefs.
And if you don't love your first pair of me undies,
they're afraid,
no questions asked me on.
He has dozens of styles and limited edition prints to help you make a statement
with your underwear.
Some freaks going to collect those,
whether anyone sees them or not.
Remember Superman I'm shipping is free in the U S and Canada.
And you can save up to $8 a pair with me undies with the me,
the me undies subscription plan.
Get the subscription plan or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's me,
undies.com/burr for 20% off your first order.
First Order,
[inaudible] dot com cipher.
Alright,
so all his shave club over there,
um,
people,
uh,
dollar shave club really appreciates you buying all this shit.
Um,
I don't read this stuff when they say I,
I dollar shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to your God damn door for
a third of the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
Uh,
you can get a fresh shave first class shave whenever you use the executive
blade,
and that's without even hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive with their Dr Carver's.
Easy Shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter carver's shave butter.
The blade gently glides across your face for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter isn't your average shape for full cream.
Yeah,
shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to join dollar shave club.
New members who buy a tube of shave butter.
Get a month of the executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this special offer today.
Today.
Today it's available by going to dollar shave club.com/burr that's dollar shave
club.com/bar oh,
he's another one.
Legal Zoom everyone.
Yeah.
Yes.
Get these other way.
All right.
Legal Zoom and I'm attention to detail is critical.
When you own a business,
that's why you should use legal zoom.
They can take care of the legal details so you can focus on growing your
business.
You already know legal zoom is a great way to start your business.
They've helped over a million people get set up the right way,
not the wrong way,
the right way.
There's more to running your business.
Then getting static supplier and customer contracts come with the territory and
if you need to hire help,
each state has its own employment laws.
What a pain in the ass there.
Don't spend valuable time researching the laws and reading print.
Let legal zoom handled that part.
They have a network of independent attorneys licensed in 48 states who know your
local laws and regulations.
They'll provide the legal answers for your day to day questions.
The best part is,
you know,
pay by the hour.
Since legal zoom isn't a law firm.
Instead you pay a low monthly fee and know exactly what you're getting up front.
So go to legal zoom.com today and spend your time growing your business instead
of worrying about legal details.
Use Bur bur in the box@checkouttosaveevenmorelegalzoom.com I don't get why they
say,
well,
we're not allowed for,
but we're going to give legal advice and we're not going to charge for by the
hour like lawyers do.
But we have a team of lawyers,
I don't know,
fucking zigzagging all over the track there.
All right.
stamps.com uh,
trips to the post office have become second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing your mailing and shipping that way for
so long.
But think about all the hassles man dropped and what you're doing driving.
They're finding parking,
parking,
getting stared at,
at the cereal place by some Weirdo with dyed hair,
despite the fact that he's bald.
There's a much better way.
stamps.com stamps.com is an easy and convenient way to get postage right from
your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer with
stamps.com there is no guesswork.
They make it easy to exact posts to get the exact postage for any letter,
any package,
any class,
a male.
The instinct,
you need it.
No expensive postage meters to least and no more trips to the post office.
You got to try it.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters whenever I'm whoring myself out
after shows.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a postage and a digital
scale.
So don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
your baby's going to cry.
Don't worry about it.
Just go into stamps.com.
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com enter
burr.
I right,
got it out of the fucking way.
Here we go.
Let's get back to the podcast.
Um,
all right.
Let's read some of the letters for this week.
We're going to leave some of the rent.
Oh,
before we,
before I do though,
the uh,
Jesus Christ,
poor Jason Law man after game one.
He's a Cleveland Guy after game one.
I can't even say game one.
After the first fucking quarter,
this guy was sending me texts,
he had like his head in the oven and I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
dude,
nobody fucking throws in the towel the way you did.
I remember back to back years,
I think in 84 the Lakers came out and blew out the Celtics in game one and we
came back and beat him.
And then the very next year we blew them out and gain one won by like 1520
fucking points.
And then the Lakers won.
So it was like for fuck sakes,
the Bruins were down o two to Vancouver.
We ended up winning for the next five and we raised,
we fucking hoisted up the cup,
stop being such a negative.
And then after the game too,
when they lost by like fucking 30 or 35,
I wrote back to him,
I maybe you've got a point.
Yeah.
Um,
I never say this app to two gains,
but this series is fucking over.
It's over man.
Just go,
go down.
If you live in Oakland,
just go fucking find a,
uh,
you know,
find a good spot for the championship parade.
This,
this is,
uh,
I dunno,
maybe they go back to Cleveland and then,
you know,
all the positivity from their fans seeps into,
I'm kidding.
Um,
here's a question.
I guess if you guys,
I didn't get why Trump got into so much fucking trouble.
You know,
I,
I will,
you know what I know,
cause he's a dope,
but like this stuff that they were saying that he said something racist,
right about the uh,
the judge Mexican American judge,
right.
Something about the fucking wall.
This is what I like to do.
And on a hot button issue in like this,
I just going to wade right in with barely,
even though in the facts it says Donald Trump's attacks on the judge,
uh,
are racist.
He's quite literally saying the judge can't do his job because of his ethnicity.
This is the definition of racism.
I guess.
He was doing some debate going on about that wall that he wants to build and
this judge who is Mexican American was going to rule on it and I think Trump
said that he didn't want him to because he was Mexican.
He was going to be biased.
So everybody's said that that was racist.
So here's my question
as a Joe 12 pack,
I'm not Joe six pack Joe 12 pack.
Um,
okay.
Basically what he did there is far as I could tell,
is how they picked juries.
Isn't that how they always pick a jury?
You know what I mean?
Like if you go down for jury duty and the defendant is black as a white dude,
yet the,
I'm not,
I'm not going to get picked for this jury or the,
the,
the defending defendant,
uh,
attorney doesn't want me on there.
Right?
Isn't that how they picked the whole,
Oh Jess,
how they always do it.
If it's a domestic violence case,
let's try to get as many women there as possible.
You know,
I think they hide it by goal because I think that they can understand women also
now they're hoping to win the fucking case.
So what they do is they stack the deck with enough people of the same ilk as the
defendant right now.
Don't they do that?
Am I nuts here?
I believe that that's what they do.
So
I thought it was kind of ironic that they within the court system that if,
if Trump is saying that,
it's like Trump's picking his jury to try to get the fucking wall.
And what he wants is he wants a bunch of fucking white people who like a white
guy goes over big disco degree to get,
Oh you,
you,
you watch how great it's going to be.
Like he wants
the mouth breathing morons that like him on his jury.
That's all he was saying as far as I could tell.
Right.
Not saying the guy's not racist,
but I thought that that one,
they were stretching the bounds a little bit.
Now I'm just asking a fucking question here.
Before you fucking edit this thing and make me look like the next Hitler,
but I was watching that story.
I'm just going like,
yeah,
that's kind of how courts work.
That's kind of exactly how it works.
And not to mention when the Oj verdict came in,
white people like what the fuck it black people were freaking out having a
parade.
That's why they do it.
Right.
Everybody watches it and you put yourself in the position of weapons there.
I watched the Oj trial.
I'm fucking,
I got my throat slashed.
Right?
Black people watch it and they go,
yeah,
I got off.
That's how I look at it.
I don't know and I don't think that's wrong either.
It's like watching sports except it's people's freedom.
Um,
alright.
Scandinavia.
Hey Billy burbles.
Uh,
is it true that you're not going to come to Scandinavia?
Me and my lady are huge fans and was really hoping fee for you to come to Sweden
this summer.
Slash.
Fall.
I just need to know if I need to book some plane tickets to the Netherlands,
then this is going to cost me like one grand for us to see your shit.
But I'll bet it's worth it.
But I just need to know if you're planning to come to Scandinavia some point in
the future.
Otherwise love your shit and looking forward to F is for family season too.
Well thank you very much.
F is for family season two is the reason why on this trip I'm not going to,
uh,
Scandinavia.
So like there's like three chunks.
Okay.
There's the my pasty people,
which is coming in first.
You know,
just like the jury
does this mean I'm a,
I'm a,
I'm a racist the way I'm touring against other white people.
Um,
no,
it's just how it worked up.
And then I probably would be do the Scandinavian thing next and then hopefully
eastern Europe.
That's what I,
I am
hoping to do.
Um,
this show takes up way more time than I thought it would,
but like they,
I had a list of 29 cities that wanted to bring me over there and I could have
gone on a month long fucking crazy ass tour.
Um,
uh,
broken it up into two.
But I think the way my workload is now,
I have to break it into three,
but like I am absolutely coming back there again.
It's a beautiful country.
Um,
I love it.
You know who the fuck doesn't want to go there?
I've been in like two or three times and uh,
I'll definitely come back.
I just don't know when,
um,
I can't promise you as to when,
but I am definitely going to come back and,
uh,
I dunno.
Other than that,
I don't have any more information.
So save your money,
dude.
Don't blow a grant.
Don't blow grant coming to see me with Shit and Dick Jokes.
I'll,
I'll come your way.
All right.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
X men billboard.
Hey billion.
This is fucking nerd shit.
Uh,
nerd shit.
So please bear with me.
There's a new x men movie and Rose McGowan,
the chick who used to date Marilyn Manson has her tits in an uproar over this
billboard because between mystique a woman and apocalypse,
it dude,
if you don't want to click on the link from some Weirdo,
you don't,
don't know.
Uh,
no problem.
Just a picture.
Just picture a blue dude holding up a naked blue woman by the throat to the
point or feet aren't on the ground contexts apocalypse.
The dude is a bad ass villain in the movie and Mystique.
The woman is the leading lady and Badass heroine in the movie.
Um,
here's the problem.
Rose McGowan says,
this is promoting violence against women,
which I feel is horseshit.
Here's why.
If it was Hugh Jackman Slash Wolverine being choked out and held up,
no problem.
The point of the posters,
a show,
how dangerous slash how much of the threat the villain,
how much of a threat the villain is.
It's not a political statement.
Here's my issue with this though.
How does a studio slash movie maker when Suppose Wolverine was the leading hero
was a women would be co women would be complaining that it's always a man as the
hero and women are more like backup or support roles.
I mean,
Ms Mystique is bad ass.
She's leading the fight against this guy.
To me that's empowering to women.
Uh,
she has an a sex symbol in the movie though Jennifer Lawrence who plays her is
really attractive.
She's just strong and a leader.
All I can think is that they wanted her standing
all,
all I can think is that they want her standing on the neck of the villain.
But this,
but that's fucking stupid.
For promotional posters.
You couldn't have her be the villain and holding up a man hero because that
would be some kind of anti woman.
All women are evil campaign instead.
Right.
Where you lost me here,
you couldn't have her be the villain and holding up a man hero.
Oh,
I see.
If she,
if,
if the female character was evil and then was holding up the guy character,
they couldn't do that because then they would be saying,
oh,
it'd be antique,
be considered anti women.
All women are evil.
Um,
I guess what bothers me is that it just seems like there's no way to please any
non white male.
Lately,
uh,
women wanted a strong female hero.
They got one,
but she's in danger of the villain.
A man,
somehow that equals violence on women when it's really just about violence in
general or war or conflict or whatever.
I mean,
the dude isn't slapping her for over cooking a steak.
He's trying to conquer the world.
She's trying to stock stop him and he's choking her ass.
How,
how is that a gender issue?
Um,
all right.
Uh,
let me see.
Let me see if I can find the picture of this year.
I did look at it,
uh,
library.
No,
that's not the f I always click on the wrong one.
Okay.
Yeah.
I actually,
you know,
when I heard it,
I thought it was bullshit,
but then I saw the poster,
the movie clip that I saw.
I don't see your feet dangling off of it.
Um,
I,
I see why they did that.
I understand why that they did it that way.
What happens is when you're writing,
what I'm learning is when you're writing something you're so fucking focused on
is the story tracking from point a to point B to point c and we land this thing
without crashing into the fucking ocean.
Um,
that they wouldn't think that anybody who,
you know,
might have a problem with that.
Um,
I understand,
I understand.
I,
this is actually one of those ones I get why they don't want to see that.
But in defense of view,
if,
how about this?
If the guy character,
the fucking Apollo Guy,
whatever his fucking name is,
was a apocalypse,
such dumb names,
apocalypse mystique,
all sound like bad cologne.
Um,
um,
anyways,
if,
if apocalypse was holding a,
the Wolverine Hugh Jackman by the throat now,
would that be promoting male on male violence?
Would there be more a bar room brawls because of that?
I honestly
don't think it promotes violence.
I think,
um,
like the level stupid that you'd have to be to look at apocalypse holding up,
pulled in a woman by her throat and to say like,
oh,
I guess it's okay to hit women.
Now I'm going to start hitting women.
If you are that fucking stupid,
by the time you got to you,
unless she was riding in the car,
let's see,
you're driving home and now you're going to fucking choker because you saw this
apocalypse guy choking a fucking mistake.
Right?
You'd also see another thousand signs on the way home and next thing you know,
I dunno,
you'd be in a car dealership buying something or uh,
getting a fucking Mcdonald's sandwich.
I think you would forget if you were that,
like if your brain was like that,
uh,
influenced,
but having said that,
a looking at the,
um,
the poster,
I ain't,
I don't,
I understand why they would just like,
you know,
that's not the greatest image.
You could have another image up there.
Yeah.
I don't have a problem with them.
Changing it,
but I definitely understand your,
um,
your points on that thing.
But,
uh,
you know,
I don't,
I don't fuck it though.
It's,
it's just the time that we're living in.
Everybody gets offended.
Everybody doesn't get offended.
A small group of people gets offended.
And I'm the news covers,
you know,
because what are they going to talk about to fucking how the drug companies in a
round about way killed prince,
you know?
I mean,
what are they gonna talk about that again,
to talk about fracking and then people didn't fucking up the water supply that
he,
there's too much money involved in that.
Okay.
But you know,
if you've got a group of fucking soccer,
mom's upset about a fucking blue woman getting held up by a guy who appears to
be made out of stone.
I'm in a movie,
you know,
that's gonna make it.
That's gonna make it.
You do a Caitlyn Jenner joke in a fucking strip mall.
Yeah,
that's going to get on the fucking news.
But real shit that matters.
Now,
that's not gonna happen.
You know,
that's not going to,
well,
why,
why now?
Why would you do that?
That's just another one of those back burners stories that they just stick on
the front burner all the fucking time.
Like they,
I mean,
I'm not saying like,
you know,
violence against women isn't a major issue,
but I'm just saying like,
people aren't,
is simplistic.
Is that like they don't fucking look at something and like,
um,
I dunno is a kid like the amount of violence that I watched when I was growing
up,
you know what I mean?
All the fucking shows that I've watched,
I've yet to chase somebody down an alley,
pull him off a fence,
chain link fence,
beat him up or even slide over the hood of a car.
I saw all those images when I was growing up.
I used to pretend and play war and all that shit.
I never fucking killed anybody.
I've never hit a woman.
I never did any of that.
I think what,
you know,
what it is is what really makes you do shit like that is,
is horrific fucking parents.
I think that that's what it is.
And now they're trying to blame the signs,
the sign that's going to be up for all of fucking two weeks when this movie's
out,
as opposed to your dad and mom and their relationship that you grow up for the
first 18 years of your life fucking watch.
And,
but you know,
you can't blame those people because those people buy things on the channel.
You know what I mean?
So you always give them a pass and then you rub their balls and you call him Joe
Sixpack and fucking,
uh,
the true heroes,
you know,
they're always rubbing their balls like they give a fuck about them.
They don't,
they just want their money.
You know what I mean?
That's why corporations act like all of these non crisis is our absolute crisis
crisis disease because they don't want to lose a fucking dime.
So if anybody bitches,
anybody Moans,
anybody complains,
they fucking cave in.
And then a lot of these groups are aware of that.
And when they get to,
uh,
to get a corporation to cave,
it gives them like it,
it's almost like a video game.
It gives them more life and,
uh,
they'd taken more seriously.
So it's a giant,
it's a giant fucking game.
You know,
at the end of the day it's say it's,
it's two people that don't fucking exist,
but,
um,
I don't know.
There's something,
there's a look on her face.
She doesn't look bad ass there.
It makes me feel bad for her and I want to help her.
So maybe what they should have done,
she should have had a more fucking a Rhonda Rousey look on her face and maybe
was pulling bex on his fucking,
are those corn
rows?
What the fuck does he have?
Was it wavy hair?
I can't,
I don't know what this guy's made out of his fucking claymation hair.
She should have.
She should be like,
you know,
maybe gouge in his eyes a little bit.
I Dunno.
I was kidding who.
They'd still fucking complain.
MMM.
If you really want to get them going,
just
have that picture right there,
that image.
Now.
I'm not going to tell you to do that because there's no sense of humor anymore.
I was gonna I was gonna say that.
Maybe you could take that image and say like,
um,
okay.
No,
don't built down it's,
it's dump asked me at a show.
I'll tell you what it was going to say.
All right.
Hey Billy,
dope.
Billy.
The fucking dope.
Can Women Forget Mr. Nice Guy.
Persona A.
Hey,
I'm really having a difficult reading today.
All right,
big fan from Lithuania.
That's another one on the list that I got to get to.
A,
you're a great comedian.
It would be great if you ever decided to do you stand up here in the Baltics.
Um,
that will happen at some point in my career.
Hopefully sooner rather than later.
All right.
The guy says,
I got it.
This dilemma,
can a woman forget your past as a nice guy.
One of my former classmates is coming back to my hometown on summer vacation for
a few weeks and let's say I'd like to get intimate with her while she's here.
Now,
the thing is,
when we were still in school,
I had a mad crush on this girl for years.
However,
Shit didn't work out because I didn't know how the life works,
how the females work.
And also I was a little bitch,
Mister Nice guy.
Uh,
I beat my younger self.
That was possible.
All right,
you're doing some good therapy here.
Uh,
but for over the years,
uh,
but over the years that I've spent in our capital city city,
I can safely say that my view and attitude towards females and masculinity,
masculinity has changed significantly.
What do you think?
Can a woman brush off the image of a nice guy or are you forever marked with the
certain character traits in her eyes?
Um,
yeah,
I think you're,
you're kind of fucked.
Just put it this way.
Like take like the actor that played like Urkel or something like that.
It's like you're typecast,
you know,
an Urkel could literally become an army fucking ranger and then leave the
military.
And when he went to go do a fucking action movie,
they bough fucking article.
Give me a fucking break.
Right.
It's just the problem is what you gotta do.
Look,
you always got to take,
you go,
he's got to take a bat.
What you're going to have to do when you get up there,
you're going to have to crowd the plate.
No Kid,
which I would just be,
you're going to have to be significantly different to raise any sort of intrigue
in her,
you know what I mean?
Cause she probably just wants to meet up with you,
you know,
have a couple of ciders or whatever that,
whatever those drinks women have when they know that they're not gonna fuck you
up.
You know,
one of those fucking,
I want to feel warm.
You know they have that stupid sweater that covers their hands too when they
drink it with both hands out of a Mug,
you know,
and it's just fucking over right there.
Like,
you know,
hit more on the waiter then the,
they didn't,
I mean listening to you,
you're going to have to lie.
I don't know.
Okay.
I Dunno what you gotta do.
Go Buy yourself a Raiders of the lost Ark Leather jacket.
You got to try to come in and act like you've been fucking doing.
So this is the thing,
this is what's going to fuck you is you want this woman too bad.
All right?
You got to not give a fuck.
Don't be,
don't be a deck,
but just go in there and just,
hey,
what's going on?
What you been up to now and then talk about some of the shit you're doing.
You know,
I don't know.
Look at your phone.
I this broad.
She's driving me crazy.
I got the ladies all over me.
I Dunno.
Doty.
I don't know what to tell you on this one.
Once you are typecast,
it's fucking over dude.
You got to go behind the camera here.
You got to start directing or some shit cause I don't know what to tell you.
Your rob.
This is what I would do.
Just know this going into it.
You're fucked.
All right?
So there's no pressure.
Who gives a shit?
And uh,
I dunno.
I'll make her laugh and just tell,
you know,
I'd always had a crush on you,
but I used to be a bitch,
but I'm not a bitch anymore.
So what do you say?
What do you say?
You come over here and a jump on my fuck enough.
You can't go that way,
but I,
yeah,
I would.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
man,
that's a tough one.
That's a tough one.
I,
you know,
maybe that's it.
Just trash your former self.
Yeah.
I used to be used to be a bitch,
you know,
I don't know how to do it,
dude.
You know what,
you've,
you've stumped me somewhere in there I think.
I think the whole not giving a fuck and then trash in your former self and then
just telling her that you had a crush on her.
Who knows?
Dude,
maybe,
uh,
I dunno.
This a chance.
Maybe she likes you back then or,
I dunno.
Women got that thing though,
Dude.
Once you're the fucking front,
it's a,
you're,
it's overdue.
So yeah,
you're fucking,
um,
oh,
the lovely Nia.
Nia,
you know,
we need you,
me and this guy from Lithuania,
I'll tell you really quickly grab a,
grab one of those chords.
All right.
Jesus.
As you're plugging in,
I'll tell you this guy basically.
And Lithuania,
he,
uh,
he used to be a bitch when it used to be mister nice guy.
So he didn't get any of the,
any of the Nice,
nice,
nicest Tracy Morgan would say.
Right?
So he,
um,
he had a crush on this chick and she got put in the friend zone is Chris Rock
would say,
I'm just going to quote every black comedian here and um,
you plugged in.
There we go.
And
you're putting a wind screen on eh,
really loud and annoying to the listeners.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
The lovely Nia.
Everybody.
Hi.
Yes.
So basically he had a crush on this girl.
He was a nice guy.
He got put in the friend zone and now she's coming back to town.
He's now living in the city.
He understands the male female dynamic better.
Okay.
And,
um,
the way he's wearing this,
he's been,
uh,
doing all right for himself.
But he still wants to bang this woman.
He's,
he,
his question is,
once you're in the friend zone like that.
Okay.
Is it possible to get out of it?
Absolutely.
It is.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
Cause I was going like,
I don't know,
I was saying to you like type cash,
you're like Urkel and now you want to be the star of an action movie,
you know?
But yeah,
no,
I think you can,
but it's all,
it's all predicated on your behavior.
Like you don't want God to all of a sudden started at yeah.
Seemed like an aloof,
a jerk or anything like that.
So I told him to buy a Raiders of the lost Ark Way.
Slink leather jacket.
Maybe get a hat and a whip.
Yeah.
Is that bad?
Uh,
I just
think maybe you're a little less available perhaps.
You know,
you know,
it can be a thing where she'll come to town and be like,
oh my God,
I could,
let's go here and do the dad.
I want to do this.
And then,
you know,
oh yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
Well,
we'll let me know when you're around.
Yeah.
Maybe we can grab a drink or something,
keep it cash and um,
don't go in there like,
so I've been fucking a lot of broad stuff.
Not like that,
but just as she's talking about her life.
You talk about your life.
Yeah.
I haven't seen it.
Girls here in there,
I don't know.
Nothing too serious,
but I've been having my fun.
But anyway,
what's going on with you?
You look good like that.
Like Neah Bay.
That was good.
Oh,
were you,
were you enjoying that just then that law and I am joined the,
the advice.
Yeah,
that was good.
Thank Youas I was stammering.
I was like,
uh,
you might have to just fuck it.
I said,
your best thing you got going is,
you know you've got no shot,
so just don't give a fuck it,
just go in there and just be like,
but I still so true.
Yeah.
You have to not get,
you can't go into it with expectations of anything.
I think you just be normal.
Be a friend like you have been.
But I think I have a friend who often gets friends owned it and I'm always
telling him that he needs to make himself less available because he always makes
himself available as them psychologically to women,
always
available as well.
Theory.
And I know it will be considered sexist,
so I'll listen to you.
The same with men and women.
If you're less available,
like the peep,
people want you more.
And I think that's just how life is.
People like the hunt.
I think men like the hunt a little more.
So I think you should remember like the hunt.
It's like a pain.
I'd be like,
oh hey.
And I'd be like,
yeah,
you're not a hunter.
Gather.
No,
I was just more like,
I hate it when women played hard to get it was so it just,
it got so boring,
so fucking fast.
I was just like,
Hey,
I can fucking,
I'll just go rub one out and then I'll go watch a game and then you know,
something that I act it's,
you're not worth the fucking trouble.
Right.
You know what I mean?
I just always found that like,
um,
cause I remember when I would just start to walk away and then these girls would
be like,
no,
you're supposed to pull blah,
blah,
blah.
I was like,
oh,
I didn't,
I didn't get the script to where my like some fucking awful play right now.
Right.
I walked away from a lot,
but I,
I,
my number could have been so much higher.
I showed a chase and then chase,
I just tapped out.
I'd be like,
ah,
you know,
if you know what I understand,
I wouldn't fuck me.
Oh,
hi.
Oh No.
Don't say that about yourself.
People like you all write a bill dill pickle.
Um,
I love a good sandwich.
My question to you is,
if you were a sandwich,
what type of sandwich would you be?
I think you already answered this one.
You could eat only one sandwich for the rest of your life.
What would you be?
All right near.
Remind the listeners what kind of sandwich you think I am.
I once compared to you to a grilled cheese sandwich.
But the thing about said you were about as exotic is a grilled cheese sandwich.
I was talking about that if,
if I ever went to prison,
the fact that I was a redhead on for the first time in my life,
I might be considered exotic.
Yeah.
And I thought you were grossly overestimating.
I was joking about the fact that quickly I would be sexually assaulted in there.
And you had to remind me that I'm a plain Jane.
There wasn't even tomatoes on that fucking grilled cheese sandwich.
She think what their hair,
I would have got something.
Fuck.
All right,
so would you like to eat for the rest of you?
I know the sandwich that I can.
This sound like this question came out of cosmo.
He were to Thanh,
which were kind of thing.
Which would you be,
if you could only eat one sandwich for the rest of your life,
what would it be?
We would never ask each other what kind of sandwich would want to be.
We'd be like,
what kind of dress are you?
A classic little black dress cocktail dress or a gown for the Oscars like that.
Well,
what up up for the bigger girls.
What about for the bigger girls when they see the bigger girls or you were car
cover with Spaghetti straps.
Stock.
I didn't like how they're just feeding your fucking egos.
Like you're all these,
yeah,
I I get what they're doing.
They're trying to sell magazines
anyway.
What kind of sandwich would you be?
Velveeta.
If I was a pair of pants,
I'd be clam diggers.
I saw like four or five guys wearing those.
Fuck it thinks,
oh this weekend.
Yeah.
Like those guys.
We have the Hitler youth haircuts and then they just walk around with the calves
up
the fucking airport
since the funniest thing ever.
I don't know why it's not so safe.
Sec.
We'll just point their legs and start laughing.
It's just me.
All right.
I love a good sandwich too.
Okay.
Um,
would I be,
I don't know.
My freckles and all that.
I'd probably be a lobster roll.
You know.
Got Crab Roll.
No,
you're looking at all fucking white with red blotches
in a day old.
Been,
that'd be my sciatic nerve problem.
I'm a mess.
It's true.
Like there are certain white people,
they definitely take on the hue of a boiled lobster and when they had to my son
and that would be me.
Um,
if you Turkey sandwich cause you like Turkey sandwiches.
Yeah,
but that's not me.
You and I know Turkey Sandwich.
You know it's,
people get excited and happy when Turkey comes around.
You know what I mean?
You're a Turkey sandwich cause you're like,
what'd you don't ever say that again?
I think you were Turkey.
This is reliable.
You're satisfied.
And when I talk I make it go to sleep.
When when consumed,
I make you sleepy.
All right.
If you could only eat one sandwich,
Nia,
for the rest of your life,
what would it be?
This feels like a lifetime movie.
Is a Philly cheese day considered a sandwich?
Cause you know,
that's my all time favorite of all time.
Well I mean it's not considered breakfast.
No,
it's considered a cereal.
All right.
So yeah,
Philly cheese steak
here.
We're always a sandwich.
Right?
Or whatever the fuck they call a hero sandwich.
So yeah,
right fucking eat one sandwich.
Rest of my life.
I'd eat a peanut butter sandwich with butter,
PB and J.
Yeah,
that's what I would have with a glass of fucking milk weight.
You'd have jelly on it though.
What do you know?
I don't want to get fat.
You put Jelly on your fucking with you.
If I could have one once.
We'll just one for the rest of my fucking light.
Why don't have to eat it every day?
No,
not every day,
but the only sandwich when you're in the mood for a sandwich,
you can only eat this particular sandwich.
I don't know.
An Italian sub.
You like Italian sandwiches?
Nah.
Then they put the oil all over and it feels like the breads sweaty.
You don't always have to get the oil.
I don't know what I'd have.
I don't,
I don't know what I would fucking have it.
It's just too know I,
I guess if I wouldn't die of a heart attack,
I'd have a roast beef sandwich.
There you go.
Bill.
You're exciting.
All right,
lady likes the belly.
Billy.
You bastard.
Love the podcast.
It was just funny.
You Bastard,
uh,
love the podcast mate.
Um,
have been following your shenanigans for nearly eight years,
hustling for tickets when you get here to London.
I got my birthday on the 3rd of August and we'll be cruising through to your gig
on the fifth.
Got You a couple of years ago and gave you a cigar after the show at the round
house in Camden.
Who knows,
maybe you smoked at course I did.
Okay,
so help me with this kind of weird dilemma of mine.
Here's the deal.
I'm six,
two,
six,
three.
On a good day,
if he's feeling good about himself,
he stands up straight and I'm fairly trim.
However,
due to my love of cake pie and all things donut I've pack,
I've packed on a mass in one specific area.
My belly.
Oh God.
That's the classic European fucking body,
you know?
Yeah.
They got those seventh grader arms and then they just got the fucking fish and
chips belly.
Generally a thinner people,
but they liked their pubs and they're like,
yeah,
they're thinner because I think their food is higher quality,
but they just don't go to the gym over there.
They walk around a lot though.
All right.
My brother loves it.
Um,
they've nicknamed me big belly Bigsby a callback to Chappelle's,
Clayton Bigsby and I've become used to,
used to giving it a good old fashioned slap from time to time.
My lady loves it too.
She rubs it,
wants to fill up with her rabbit food.
Uh,
she's Vegan,
whatever,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
It's a mind fuck subverts the whole guys got to have a pack vibe.
You losing me here.
Anyways,
I'm going to keep on going Michelangelo on this bitch and getting into shape at
the risk of losing the failsafe laughter of the day.
What do you think?
Yeah,
dude,
you don't want to be the fat guy who slaps his belly like a fucking walrus
looking for a mate.
And if you don't mind data under control,
it's going to get bigger and bigger and it's going to be bad for your health.
So trust me,
your girlfriend might love the belly right now,
but she's going to really love that section
back.
I really,
what if she's insecure?
She's worried that he's going to go out and fucking start doing the full Monte
someplace,
both work.
And get the six pack together.
Although she might already have it since she's a Vegan and it never happens.
And to keep what couples could never work out.
I don't like,
yeah,
I'm not into it.
But remember we tried to work out and I was just yelling.
You push it.
I don't want,
no,
we never worked out together like that.
We will go to the gym together,
her thing and I would do,
we always do.
We go to a party.
What did we do?
We go in different separate words.
Yeah.
I came here to have a good time.
Not to be,
got to be with the person I live with.
I came here.
Yeah.
I live with Deanna.
I don't need to hang out with you at this point.
So what's going on with you in this new environment?
All right.
I get to know your girlfriend's going to love the six bag,
so keep at it and like to keep a belly just so people can slap it around.
So you can be that guy at the party after a while.
Yeah,
that's pathetic.
It's better to get shredded and be,
you know,
real Michael Lynch.
Hello.
Yeah.
Then you get to walk around being a Dick,
being aloof,
you know,
you just,
every time people talk to you,
you pretend you're looking at something down the street with the fucking
eyebrows up.
Sorry man.
It's got to keep on moving.
You know,
I'm like a shark.
Can you talk about that poster a yeah,
no,
I missed that.
Yeah.
The guy that she brought up a bunch of great points,
which is,
well I don't know if you want to go back and read it.
Um,
I can't,
I don't remember.
He was just saying like,
well no,
15 was like,
whoa,
here's one that I made it.
If he was holding up Hugh Jackman,
would that increase the chances of guys fighting other guys?
I don't think it's about like increasing,
like influencing people to do it.
It's just like,
it's just not,
well,
they said it,
it isn't a great look.
I actually,
I don't think it's a good poster,
but I would say that I don't think it promotes violence against women.
I wouldn't think so.
We are there,
but although I'm not trying to speak for blue women though.
That's right.
Uh,
they can speak for themselves.
No,
I don't know.
I saw that poster and I first of all couldn't tell it was a woman,
but if I was like well versed in that whole thing,
I would be like,
oh,
that's such and such character.
Uh,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't know.
But I think it's probably best that they,
they're all in the,
all the different poster I was saying.
They're all named after like discontinued colognes and I'm like,
what mystique apocalypse.
Just sounds like.
It's like whoever came up with Zima then tried to get into Cologne and it all
fucking bombed.
Right.
Listen,
I'm fortunately got to stop the podcast cause I gotta go to work.
Boom.
Bump off the to to,
to,
to do loo do.
All right.
Thank you guys for listening and um,
I'll let you guys know about those Presales,
um,
for the upcoming dates in Ireland and a thank you to everybody that's been
buying tickets in Scotland,
in Amsterdam and London and a second show in London,
Nini.
That's so great.
Yeah.
When I phoned us,
the Gabba where I can fucking smoke a stick after.
I love that.
Nice big picture of fucking,
I don't know,
Winston Churchill Isam.
Shit would be wonderful,
right?
We gotta fight under here.
Is that Winston Churchill?
It's already made.
All right.
Winston Churchill in front.
I think ace is high.
I believe it was.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll check in on your Thursday.